[Musique]
elise baisse à la bvk vérifier sur of
time famille de stephen king road dates
est vraie équation would have the same
les audiences américaines surtout des
acquisitions
ma fille à aïda
ça a très bien marché à ida était
scolarisé en septembre dernier
depuis ce jour nous tenant un tête à
tête quotidien pour réviser les leçons
du jour éventuellement révisée seul
préparer celle du lendemain
au départ tout était nouveau pour elle
les chiffres les lettres les mots mais
le plus important les concepts donc les
jours s'enchaînent et les difficultés à
trouver des explications simples et
claires aussi une fois dans le livre
d'éducation scientifique et
technologique
oui je vous assure ça existe c'est là où
là il était question de définir deux
états de la matière vous amusez vous
imaginez pour un enfant de 5 ans la
question était c'est quoi un solide
c'est quoi un liquide et dans le livre
la définition disait que un objet et 18
litres
si j'arrive à tenir dans ma main il est
l'équipe dans le cas contraire autant
que physicien j'ai trouvé cette
définition simple d'une efficacité
redoutable
mais au fond je sais qu'elle est vague
et imprécise donc pour tester cette
définition
je suis venu ici aujourd'hui pour vous
poser une question la voici
le sable est ce qu'il est solide ou
liquide
oui
vous avez raison la réponse à cette
question n'est pas simple
et je suppose que le concepteur du livre
scolaire n'a certainement pas penser aux
sables lorsqu'il a apporté cette
définition là pour répondre à la
question
j'ai par amener avec moi du sable nous
allons faire une expérience qu'on peut
très bien faire avec l'esprit ce que
disent les allemands ils disent guide
externe est une expérience avec l'esprit
mais que vous pouvez faire chez vous à
la maison son problème si on verse du
sable sur une table le sable va se
déposer pour former un dépôt qui sera
parfaitement à l'équilibré
contrairement à l'eau qu'ils se
mettraient à l'horizontale
ce dépôt de sable qu'on appelle un tas
peut même supporter une charge comme un
solide gaillard
maintenant si j'inclus la table le sable
va couler comme un liquide donc cette
faculté à être à la fois solide et
l'équipe
sachez que ce n'est pas une spécificité
du sable seul mais en fait c'est une
caractéristique générale de tous les
membres d'une grande famille qu'on
appelle la matière en gras ou bien les
matériaux granulaires les matériaux
granulaires sont en fait omniprésent
dans notre quotidien et même à l'échelle
de l'univers
on peut citer ici quelques exemples
ça peut être du sucre en poudre ou en
morceaux
ça peut être du riz ça peut être du fric
pour siobhan ça peut être du couscous du
balcon crise ça peut être tous les
légumes secs en fait tous les fruits
secs mais pas seulement
la matière en grains peut se présenter
sous la forme de poudre pharmaceutique
de gravier ballasts pour chemin de fer
las pour chemin de fer mais aussi ça
peut être la matière dont est composé
les du ce soit ici en algérie où sur la
planète mars ou même la matière qui
compose d annuler les anneaux de saturne
donc en fait la matière en grains
elle est omniprésente partout même en
géophysique et même en astronomie donc
la compréhension de ces milieux
granulaires est en fait engage un jeu
socio économiques et industrielles qui
est très important au départ cette
science était est resté pendant
longtemps l'apanage des ingénieurs et
des géophysiciens mais depuis une
vingtaine d'années la matière en gras
est devenu le terrain de jeu pour un
certain nombre de physiciens dont je
fais partie donc vous ne diriez mais
pourquoi cet engouement soudain pour la
matière en gras pour les physiciens qui
d'habitude traite les questions
fondamentales
mais en fait à matière en gras elle
suscite la curiosité
elle pose des problèmes et des défis en
fait elle met même en péril des théories
physiques qui sent très bien établie la
science physique de la matière en grains
est en quelque sorte du sens hybride
elle se trouve à cheval sur la physique
statistique
la mécanique est sur la physique des
milieux désordonnée mais il faut savoir
que depuis longtemps l'homme a compris
que le sable cool comme l équipe
au départ nous avions d horloge à eau
qu'on appelle les clepsydre et très vite
elles ont laissé leur place ou sablier
et cela pour une très bonne raison le
débit des grains dans le sablier est
constant et régulier
contrairement au débit de l'eau dans la
clepsydre qui lui va diminuer lorsque la
hauteur d'eau dans la partie supérieure
de la clepsydre va diminuer qu'est ce
qui se passe dans le sablier au niveau
d'étranglement en fait les grains à ce
niveau là ne ressentent que la pression
des couches et voisines mais vraiment
très voisines et tout le poids des
couches supérieures et dirigé
latéralement
avec ce qu'on appelle d'échelle de force
ou des réseaux
contact c'est ce qu'on appelle les
délais fait de voûte qui est très bien
connu en génie civil bon j'ai choisi une
image l'alhambra ici donc on voit les
arches et les voûtes
alors cet effet de voûte
en fait il peut être utilisé à bon
escient par exemple pour réduire d'une
manière drastique la pression que peut
exercer le poids d'un train sur des
rails et des traverses de chemin de fer
c'est pour ça on utilise de ballast mais
toujours cet effet darche peut-être
pernicieux et la cause de pas mal de
dégâts
si je prends par exemple le cas d'un
silo à grains si les parois latérales ne
sont pas renforcées elles peuvent subir
localement des pressions très
importantes et épouse et par là même des
dégâts
donc pour vous convaincre un peu de cet
effet de voûte
je vais encore une fois vous inviter à
faire avec moi juste avec l'esprit
quelques expériences que vous pouvez
faire avec soin vos frères et soeurs
soit avec vos enfants à la première fois
que j'ai vu cette expérience c'était feu
pierre gilles de gennes qui avait fait
ça l'université de strasbourg
alors prenons une éprouvette en verre
remplis sans la moitié avec du sable sec
et fin maintenant donné quelques tapes
sur le vert pour compacter le sable est
retourné l'éprouvette sens dessus
dessous
surprise le sable ne coulera pas
pourquoi parce qu'en fait il ya une
espèce darche qui va se former avec les
gras qui va empêcher le grain de couler
la deuxième expérience toujours
impressionnante est la suivante si vous
prenez un turbo un cylindre vite dans
lequel vous tenez bien droit un bâton en
bois remplie c'est le tube avec du sable
fin et sec donner des coups sur le tube
pour compacter le sable est maintenant
essayer de retirer le battant à la
verticale vous verrez que ces prix dits
fils
voire impossible à faire l'un pour
arnold schwarzenegger ceci ressemble
beaucoup vous avez peut-être tous fait
cette expérience
lorsque vous avez essayé de retirer le
pied d'un parasol de la plage lorsque
vous l'avez en français tôt le matin
revenons maintenant un peu à notre chère
sabliers si l'on regarde la partie
inférieure du sablier le sable lorsqu'il
cool pour ceux déposés
il ne se met pas à l'horizontale comme
je l'aï dit tout à l'heure comme un
liquide à l' équilibre
en fait ils forment un camp de
révolution avec un angle au sommet qui
est très bien défini ce tas se forment
en fait d'une manière totalement
autonome
il se forme à partir du succession
d'avalanches est en fait dans la nature
il y a quelqu'un qui a précédé les
physiciens de la matière en gras il y a
est-ce que vous pouvez éteindre s'il
vous plaît la lumière il y à ce qu'on
appelle la larve dufour millions lalart
dufour millions en fait qu'est ce
qu'elle fait à la compris en fait le
fonctionnement des avalanches elle
construit un piège
impitoyable dont tôt qu'une fourmi nous
sortir a sauvé en fait ce piège et la
forme d'un trou avec une pente qui se
trouvent à l'état d' équilibre
métastable ou critique
lorsqu une fourmi passe à côté du trou
la larve qu'est ce qu'elle fait il
suffit qu'elle projette quelques grains
de sable sur la pente et déclenché une
avalanche qui va entraîner
inexorablement la fourmi v'là le vers le
trou ça c'est dans la nature
toujours avec des expériences
fantastiques avec la matière en grains
je vous invite à faire une autre
expérience chez vous qui coûte rien du
tout prenez un bol
météo font deux ou trois noix et
complété avec des lois êtes ou même des
pois chiches
maintenant ce que vous allez faire c'est
que vous allez secouait verticalement le
bol ou bien vous donner des petites
tapes en dessous suffisamment longtemps
et qu'est ce que vous allez remarquer
vous allez voir que les noix qui était
enfant c'est à l'intérieur du tas elles
vont remonter tout seul quand par magie
à la surface et en plus de ça elles vont
s'agréger elles vont se mettre ensemble
cet effet on l'appelle la ségrégation
bon c'est pas très joli mais c'est le
cas de le dire
alors le phénomène de ces gros de
ségrégation est à premier abord en
contradiction avec le second principe de
la thermodynamique
pourquoi parce que plus vous essaierez
d'agiter le bol pour mélanger l'ensemble
des lois c'est à dire introduire du
désordre
qu'est-ce qui se passe les lois se
séparent il y a de l'ordre qui se
forment
donc vous voyez tout le défi qu'on a
avec la physique des gras et donc ce
phénomène de de ségrégation il faut
savoir qu'il peut être très pernicieux
pour un très grand nombre d'applications
industrielles
si on prend par exemple la fusée ariane
son combustible
il n'est pas liquide c'est un mélange de
poudre donc lorsqu'on va le transporter
si le chemin n'est pas bien goudronnées
c'est à dire il peut y avoir des
aspérités ou des trous donc les
vibrations qu'est ce qu'elles vont faire
elles vont séparer les poudres la
mélange de poudres en différentes poules
et ça ça peut entraîner un
dysfonctionnement dans le décollage de
la fusée
maintenant je vous invite à quitter la
cuisine pour faire une petite balade au
bord de la mer et là lorsque vous
marchez sur le sable mouillé qu'est-ce
que vous remarquez vous remarqué que
vous pouvez éteindre s'il vous plaît
vous remarqué que sous votre pied le sol
ça sèche
on le voit bien ici
en fait qu'est ce qui se passe lorsque
vous
exercer une pression avec votre poids
sur le sable mouillé
l'ol est absorbée elle est aspiré au
lieu d'être expulsés et ça c'est
exactement l'effet contraire d'une et
penche toujours sur une plage vous avez
probablement tous éprouvé après une
séance de course à pied ou un match de
foot sur le sable une très grosse
fatigue
ceci n'est probablement pas due à la
tenue sportive que vous avez choisi mais
en fait l'explication elle est très
simple c'est que le sable à l'instar de
tous les milieux granulaires cent des
systèmes hautement dissipatifs autrement
dit les forces de frottement et les
chocs entre les gras engloutissent toute
l'énergie que vous pouvez mettre dans ce
type de système vous savez bien que
l'algérie est couverte à plus de 80% des
le désert de prix de 2 millions de
kilomètres carrés et là c'est ses
propriétés extraordinaires de la matière
en gras le devient encore plus dans le
sahara le tas de sable dans le désert on
l'appelle une dune
il faut savoir que les dunes ne sent pas
unique
c'est comme les êtres humains et elle
est d'une sous forme de croissant qui
n'a qu on appelle les barkhanes est allé
d'une géante sous la forme d'une étoile
est allée du longiligne qu'on appelle
safe pour épée mais c'est d'une il faut
savoir aussi que c'est des entités
vivantes à part entière parce qu'elle
naisse elles grandissent et elle se
déplace au gré des vents et plus que ça
les dunes elle chante
oui oui vous entendez bien les dunettes
chante d'une voix puissante et
harmonieuse d'ailleurs vous pouvez
demander aux bédouins dans le sud qui
connaissent ces champ de dunes
ils vous diront qu'en fait ce sens les
jeans a pas les pantalons et les djinns
les esprits qui peuplent les contrées
vaste du désert qui sont derrière et qui
sont à l'origine de ces chants
envoûtants
alors vous voyez maintenant et vous
savez que la matière en gras suscite la
curiosité en présent en se présentant
avec des propriétés totalement contre
intuitive et jusqu'à aujourd'hui nous
nous avons beaucoup de mal à expliquer
ces phénomènes liés à la matière en gras
mais en egypte antique par exemple les
ingénieurs bâtisseurs utilisé le sable
dans leurs oeuvres avec une très grande
maîtrise non seulement ils ont inventé
le mortier mais aussi utilisé le sable
pour ériger des grand obélisque en les
faisant glisser dans des silos remplis
de sable quand vie d'après il savait
aussi qu'il était beaucoup plus aisé de
déplacés de grands monuments comme sur
cet euro glyphes il est plus aisé de
déplacer les grands monuments en les
faisant des plats glisser sur des bancs
sur lesquels en mai un sable qu'il est
ni trop sec ni trop mouillé alors
jusqu'à aujourd'hui il y a personne qui
a pu élaborer une théorie générale ou
bien une théorie analytique dans
laquelle on explique tous ces phénomènes
étranges dans un même format lisent
comme il se fait par exemple en
hydrostatique en hydrodynamique ou même
en électromagnétisme pierre gilles de
gennes prix nobel de physique
le saint patron des cristaux liquides un
esprit bien curieux vers la fin de sa
vie il a remis au goût du jour la
physique et la science des gras il
disait à propos de celle ci la science
des grains n'est pas coûteuse peut jouer
avec du sable des lentilles des
putschistes scrute tout ce que vous
voulez la science des grains n'est pas
coûteuse mais elle est très soigneuse et
il disait aussi parce que la matière
désordonnée est caractérisée par un
désordre
il disait que le désordre à l'échelle
microscopique c'est un animal bien
dressés il est domptée
mais le désordre à l'échelle
macroscopique comme c'est le cas dans la
matière en gras ils exigent
ij en fait de nouveaux explorateurs donc
avec une petite dose de naïveté
on peut penser que avec une pelle un
seau à l'entonnoir
on peut proposer dpf projet de fin
d'études on peut encadrer des thèses et
puis pourquoi pas délocaliser son bureau
et son laboratoire de recherche pour le
mettre dans un bac à sable au fond d'un
jardin d'enfants ou dans un coin de
désert ou de plage n'est ce pas un
instinct qui disait que jouer c'est
peut-être la forme la plus élevée la
plus élaborée de la recherche
alors sincèrement je vous invite à jouer
avec du sable à vous amuser avec des
légumes secs chez vous peut-être ainsi
vous dit si près le brouillard sur l'une
des problèmes problématiques
fondamentales de la physique actuelle
par la même occasion vous trouverez
peut-être des solutions pour stopper
l'avancée du désert
ô combien importante pour notre pays
vous pouvez peut-être même trouver des
solutions à l'érosion des plages et des
weight
mais plus que ça vous pouvez même
trouver des solutions pour désengorger
les embouteillages monstres de la
capitale alger merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]